Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and we are going to do a little midi-medicine
of anxiety.
Can I title this, taby in the mud, sir, that chases us because that's often what it can
feel like when we're anxious, when we're fearful, when we're scared of our condition or anxious
about our future.
So no way, obviously, is this going to be extensive and we are just going to touch on some points
that I just really feel like to talk to you guys about that I think will be helpful.
So first of all, we talk about anxiety, we have to talk about biochemical imbalances because
from a neurotransmitter standpoint, the biochemical imbalances can be rampant with anxiety.
That's what this little picture says, GAD symptoms, GAD stands for the gene that we look at
when we look at your genetics.
There are multiple genes in the sequence of breaking down glutamate to make glutamates and
then breaking down glutamates so you don't have excess glutamates.
And again, one defects and there's some DAO defects and AO defects and multiple other defects
that can be in these pathways that can leave a person with their brain having excess glutamates.
Now glutamate is a neurotransmitter that is necessary for your body.
We need glutamate to wake up in the morning, we need glutamate to study and to think people
with excess glutamates tend to be better students at different times in their life tend to be
able to be focused, tend to be drivers, tend to be entrepreneurs, tend to be very creative,
have many wonderful gifts and it's partly due to that glutamate in their brain that's just
worried and their might is thinking, however, excess glutamate can lead to OCD-like symptoms
perseveration of thought, can't seem to let things go and anxiety, nail biting, nervousness,
worry wart and that's what we want to prevent.
It's about balance, remember, there's nothing good or bad when we talk about chemicals in our
body, it's about having that balance to little of something can cause problems, too much of
something can cause problems, we're talking about anxiety and worry and fear, especially excess,
we're talking about glutamate as a neurotransmitter in your brain.
So we want to do, we're talking about excess glutamates, so we want to reduce glutamates in your
brain. Now understand that the food industry purposely puts glutamates in our foods because glutamate
is an excitatory neurotransmitter, so because it's an excitatory neurotransmitter, if you eat a
glutamate, it signals to your brain those receptors and it turns out your brain and you get this rush
of a high and that can make us think that this food really tastes good. So the food industry understands
neuroscience, so they purposely put glutamates in our foods and understand there's about 25 different
glutamates that are commonly used in food additives in order to stimulate glutamate receptors of the
brain, so it makes you think this food is really tasty and you want to buy more and then they sell more.
So it's all about increased sales, it's all about making the food taste better, it's considered a
flavor enhancer, and because glutamates are quote unquote natural, even though these are synthetic
made in the laboratory that are put in our food industry, they don't have to be labeled as glutamates,
they're only labeled as natural and artificial flavorates. They'll understand for further information
on the genetic piece and glutamates and such, I want to refer you to our genetic videos or I go over
this ad nausea with dealing with genetic defects and looking at your genes to be able to determine whether
you have, you know, presuppositions to your handling of a glutamate, getting rid of
body, converting glutamate to glutamate, glutamate to glutamate to glutamate to quickly, and we go over
those in detail, and if we haven't gone over your genetics, it'll be a good time to look at that.
But step number one is to reduce glutamates in your food, and that would be really to start eating more
organic, start cooking your own meals. Stop buying pre-prepared foods because that's what's going
to have glutamates in it. Flavored chips, flavored foods, flavored meals, foods that have artificial
flavoring to the chips that have, you know, onion and sour cream flavoring in it, Doritos,
those kind of things are going to be very high in glutamates. You've heard of modusodium glutamate,
modusodium glutamate is just one of those 25 different glutamates that they put in different foods.
Secondly, if a person is going to have very high glutamate levels, very high anxiety levels,
we want to also think about decreasing their protein content of their diet, decreasing the
meat and eggs and beans that they would be eating. Certainly we're not eliminating those but decreasing
those because those contain glutamine, which is an amino acid, which is what proteins are made
on of amino acids. Glutamine is one of those amino acids that are in the protein that break down to
make glutamates. So if I have defects in genes that break down glutamate quite quickly to glutamate,
then also genes that don't allow glutamate to be broken down and gotten rid of are going to have
excess glutamate. Many times with kids that we see with these issues, they have defects on those
genes and they tend to be just carnivorous kids that only like some, you know, cheese products or
chicken nuggets or that's all we can get Johnny to eat. So they are basically feeding this addiction
to glutamates, which is the stimulation of their brain, and that can be very dangerous because it can
lead to all these OCD type symptoms and anxiety type symptoms. It even works with that long term.
It really leads to damage of these neurons and there's numerous studies that are coming out that
high levels of glutamate are a big contributor to early dementia and such too. So it's something that
that everyone should be taking serious, that's why we should be eating organic, that's why we should
be staying away from exogenous glutamates. And if you do have an already eating organic and doing this
and still have a lot of anxiety, think about cutting back on the proteins or at least mixing your
proteins with your carbohydrates and fats so that the breakdown is dramatic and quickly into the
bloodstream and into the cells. Some products to think about with this from the biochemical
standpoint are a product that we use called glutamate scavenger two. That is a great product to get
rid of glutamates. If you're really dealing with a lot of anxiety, we might have to go to a product
called Benagine which is an oxaloacetate product that is better at crossing the blood brain barrier
to pull out the glutamates in the brain. That can be a better product. This is a little bit more
pricey. CBD oil has also been proven to help with this too. That would be something that I would
consider as well. Besides biochemical issues, there's emotional issues with anxiety. So we need to
address that piece as well. I would suggest you pause this video at this time and take a screenshot
of these Bible verses because the word of God talks a lot about anxiety. God doesn't just leave us
alone here on earth. He knows that we're going to go through struggles and he said, let today's
own struggles be enough for today. We're going to have struggles. That's one day that we're guaranteed
on this earth. It's not going to be easy regardless of what the prosperity theologians want to tell us.
The truth is that God will walk along with you in your troubles and the troubles are there to help
us depend on him even more. So here's some verses that can help walk you through that. Some different
practical tips that can help us with the emotional side is some things that I use. I have high
glutamate issues. I've been a nail miter since I was a kid and tend to be more of a warrior
player. I'm always thinking ahead and I'm just going to give you some practical things that I've
learned over the years. Number one is to really stay grounded in the truth. I did another video
about this information just a week or so ago. This is key. If you don't know who you are in
Christ and what your purpose here on earth is, you anxiety is going to even read rampant in your life.
You have to stay grounded in the truth of the plan that God has for you. The only way I can tell you
to do that is to study. You've got to be opening up your Bible. You've got to be listening to good things,
listening to good sermons, listening to reading good books. That's the only way I can say in the
scripture is very clear that we are supposed to study to show themselves approved. We're supposed
to do that. You have the ability to read and learn and say, I'm surprised at how many people
can pick up a novel and read some trashy novel, but they can't pick up their Bible and read that.
But I'm not talking from a legalistic standpoint that, oh, your problem is all you need to do is start
reading your Bible. That's not what I'm talking about. You read other things. You listen to other things.
Your listening, your watching Oprah or whatever on television, you need to be starting putting good
things in between your ears. And I don't know how else to say it. I'm not talking from a legalistic
standpoint. We just got to be realists here. I have a big fan of audible. I've told you before that I
grew up completely dyslexic. I couldn't read a book until I was in seed year high when I took up
running as a sport in cross country and learned that the cross crawlback. It is what really
helped with dyslexia. And that's why I went into the profession that I did. But I'm still very much
an audible and auditory learner. So I listen to books. Plus, I don't have time. I tend to want to
multitask. So when I'm cutting the grass or doing work at home or doing something that doesn't
take a lot of thought process, I'm also listening to a book on tape. And audible is one of my favorite
apps on my cell phone. I listen to probably anywhere between 1, 2, 2, 3 books a week on audible.
Also, there's tons of great servants and videos on YouTube that you can search and
be gaining information and grounding yourself in positive things in the truth and who you are in
Christ so that it will help take that edge off your tendency to worry and have anxiety. So people
don't have that issue. I get it goes back to that genetic component that you're going to be more
predisposed to that. Other things, have reminders of the truth. Grounded in the truth, yes, you need
to study to show yourself a proof. But also have reminders of the truth. Listen to good music. What are
you choosing to listen to? What are you choosing to do for your entertainment at night? What shows
are you watching? What movies are you going to? I highly recommend that you limit your social media time.
So many times, especially with young people, but it can be with adults as well, that you start comparing
yourself one person to another and you start seeing your friends profile and social media and you start
thinking, oh my gosh, they have such a perfect life. I don't, well, the truth is that many times that
person is pretending to have the perfect life because they feel the same way you do. So you might
want to go on a social media faster and do as fast to just stay away from that stuff and get
your head on straight with this. Have friends that are going to hold you accountable. That's a key
component. I am blessed to have a wife who's my best friend and she holds me accountable and is willing
to tell me hard things. Doesn't allow me to feel sorry for myself. I've said it multiple times before
that pity is a luxury. I cannot afford and you need to have friends that are willing to hold you
to that so that you don't fall into that because really when we talk about anxiety and worry,
much of that comes from a self-centeredness. I'm worried about myself or I'm worried about,
you know, even if oh, I'm not worried about myself, I'm worried about my children. Well,
again, that is still an inwardly luckyness and we need to have friends that will, yes, that will be
willing to be there and cry with us. We need to express that grief and get that emotion out. There's
huge benefits to that, but also we need friends that will slap us sometimes and just tell us to,
hey, shake it off though, you know, all you're thinking is selfish thoughts here and have that
authentic love, which is very different than the false love doctor that's kind of out there in the
churches today that we just kind of love it except everybody, but we need to love people,
but we also need to tell them the truth so that it's not disvaluing them, but it's keeping them focused
on what is right and good and what they should be focused on. And we need those kind of relationships.
So if you don't have that with your spouse or significant other or friends in your life,
seek out a good church where you could develop some relationships that have that authentic love
relationships that people can be maybe some people that you have in your life that are more mature
than you that can hold you accountable to what is right and good and keep your mind focused on what
is right and good. And then we all have to be facing our giants. Sometimes that giant in our life is
this excessive need to be in control, maybe because we were abused in the past or maybe because
that now because of that abuse, we feel like we have to need to be in control. That could actually
even be an idol in our life that need to be in control. Face in our giants and our view of God too.
God is not your Santa Claus and I see this quite often that when people pray for something that they
want, whether it be healing from their cancer or healing from their financial woes that they have
or whatever problem that they're going through. And God doesn't give you the answer that you want.
What's revealed is the fact that you thought that you could basically manipulate him to get everything
you want. Well, he's not your Santa Claus. His ultimate purpose in your life is to mold you and shape
you to the image of his son so that he can experience you forever in heaven. And when we have the selfish
thoughts of even our view of him, then we're going to be very disappointed and I'd recommend that
goes back to being grounded, study, approved, listened to good servants that are teaching the truth
about false concepts that are self-centered. And then make sure we have perspective. I'm very big
on perspective. I feel like we spent time in our earlier years back in the 90s where we did full-time
missionary work and at that time we had four children and our youngest was pretty our youngest
at that time. Our fourth one was pretty young just a couple of years old so she doesn't really
remember it. I wish we would have spent more time in our later years of our marriage,
bringing our kids to continue to bring our kids to mission trips and to see the other side of life.
Will you, if you live in the United States, you are living in affluence unless you are in an intercity
situation in utter poverty but it would always be good to I'd recommend that you keep a perspective
on your life. Go help in the soup kitchen. I've told some patients that you need to go volunteer
in a soup kitchen. You need to go volunteer with some street people. You need to go on a mission trip
because the things that we wide about sometimes are so unbelievably self-centered that we have no
perspective of how the rest of the 95% of this, the people in this world actually live, that we need
to keep that perspective. Again, I'm not talking about that there needs to be times that we that we
do express our emotion and that we do have somebody that we can pry on their shoulder. That's not
what I'm speaking about but what our life is, is constantly focused on poor me, huckabits.goi in the
way. I want it to go and that's what's the cause of your anxiety. We need to, we need to gain that
perspective or that gets back to having a friend that sometimes will slap us in the face and wake us up
a little bit. That's part of which you're in and it's a process that is painful sometimes so
we need to walk through that. There's also some physical techniques that can help us with anxiety,
some practical helps. Are we getting proper sleep? Are we getting some fresh air? Are we dealing with
stressful situations? Are we being realistic with ourselves? Are we trying to put too many things on
our plate that we really shouldn't be putting on our plate? Are we dealing with past wounds? We never
want to, to, to minimize wounds of the past, people that have been abused, that need to get
cold sleep. Highly suggest you get into a Christian counselor that can help you work through some of
those things in the past. And to make sure you're not in situations of current toxic relationships and
I know some of you might be hearing this and go, well, you don't know what my husband or my wife is
like in a toxic relationship right now. Well, that's where you need to seek counsel outside of your
home life with some friends that are more mature than you that can help counsel you through that and
help you through that, even if you're in a relationship that you can't make go away easily.
Know that we're here to pray with you all the time. So if you need prayer, that's going to be a
key component. Know that the enemy is trying to attack you all the time so that you need to be
prayed for protection from him, because that's what he wants is to steal your joy and to kill your
spirit and to destroy your hope. And we need to be prayed against that at all time. And we're here for
you for that too. So contact us if you need us. I hope this is an encouragement for you and we will talk
again.